foreign
[Music]
tonight concerns cryptocurrency the only
word that makes Elon Musk not
immediately
we first covered crypto five years ago
when I was 10 years younger and since
then a lot has happened including
unfortunately this video from just last
year promoting the general concept of
trading crypto
hello
it's me
would you like to learn about exchanging
cryptocurrency will go over
everything everything
is you got coins from different
blockchains and wanna do some trading I
mean a lot to dislike about that from
her choosing to parody a song by one of
our greatest singers while having a
voice that I can only describe as a no
chair turn to wearing those earrings
which scream I do my best shopping at
airports to the fact that her name is
Randy Zuckerberg and yes she is Mark's
sister meaning that incredibly she is
the cool one in that family and that
wasn't even the only song that she did
she also did this one about how
everything with crypto was gonna go
great
we're all gonna make it
yeah we're all gonna make it
we're all gonna make it everyone
yep we're all gonna make it in crypto is
a phrase that's aged about as well as
welcome aboard the unsinkable Titanic
those videos came out when crypto FIFA
was still near its absolute Peak
stadiums were getting named after crypto
companies Matt Damon and LeBron James
did commercials for crypto.com and
celebrities from Larry David to Tom and
Gisele pre-divorce but post love hyped a
crypto exchange called FTX that was run
by a 29 year old supposed genius Named
Sam bankman freed AKA SPF he was on the
cover of Forbes and Fortune with one
calling him the next Warren Buffett and
others calling him jpeg Morgan and
Sequoia Capital One of the biggest
Venture Capital firms had a 213 million
dollar investment in the company but
since then to put it mildly there has
been an implosion which really broke
through to public Consciousness just
before last Christmas
in a span of 24 hours Sam bankman freed
was whisked by federal agents in the
Bahamas to New York City where he faced
a judge and walked out of a federal
courthouse after posting bail on a 250
million dollar bond which prosecutors
believe is one of the largest in U.S
history right SPF was arrested for
defrauding his customers out of billions
of dollars and to be honest it seems
like the courtroom sketch artist may
have been one of them because this is
one of the rudest illustrations I've
ever seen the whole innocent until
proven guilty thing clearly doesn't
apply to the side of the law with the
coloring pencils
arrest was a big deal and his company
imploded some like cnbc's Jim Cramer
were Furious
idiot he's a path high school he's a
kind man we're talking about nearly four
years of getting away with financial
murder just because they could why
those are some harsh words there from
these squawking parrot on every Pirate's
shoulder especially as just a year
earlier Kramer was saying this tonight
we're going to educate ourselves with
Sam bankman free well Sam I got to tell
you Snyder to have you because I think
you're pretty much a Visionary yeah not
great but also not surprising after all
this is the same guy that proclaimed
that bear Stearns is fine literally days
before it folded told his viewers to buy
Netflix right before it lost almost 70
percent in five months and once and this
is true said that Google Facebook and
Twitter should hire Kevin Spacey as a
spokesperson Jim Cramer is the only
person who could look you in the eye say
you are going to die tomorrow and give
you an immediate sense of calm knowing
that you're going to live for another 50
years
but FTX has been just one of the many
dominoes that fell in the crypto world
over the past two years the market value
of all cryptocurrencies fell from around
3 trillion in late 2021 to around 1
trillion last year and there are small
investors who got badly hurt by all of
this one in five Americans has invested
in traded or used cryptocurrency and you
can find countless stories of people
losing most of their life savings in the
recent implosions underscoring that
everyone in crypto was never actually
going to make it no matter how much
Randy Zuckerberg screams sang otherwise
so tonight we thought we'd take a look
at what has been happening in the world
of crypto by looking at three of the
biggest collapses over the past year
each of these companies was founded on
the promise that they would replace some
part of our financial system there is
Terror a cryptocurrency Celsius a crypto
bank and FTX a crypto trading platform
in theory they were supposed to be our
next dollar our next Bank of America and
our next Stock Exchange but in reality
they are fiascos and before we start
we're not going to be discussing the
merits or the technology of the
blockchain we did that five years ago
it's still on the internet you can go
watch it there or not not watching this
show is always a strong option for you
but
just as a reminder every single crypto
coin is just something someone with a
laptop made up that is true for all of
them like Dogecoin cat coin Panda coin
furry coin come rockets Elon sperm and
Monkey Juice those are all real by the
way we were going to come up with a fake
one as a joke but then we saw monkey
jizz and it felt like a hat on a hat
to the extent any of these coins have
value it's based on whether people
believe they do which often comes down
to their confidence in the person or
group who made the coin and that basic
fact makes the crypto business very
attractive to a certain type of person
one columnist who's covered this
intensively sums it up like this if you
are running a scam you will be drawn to
crypto you are running a confidence game
and crypto offers the most efficient
market for turning confidence into money
and the story for all three companies
that we're going to look at tonight is
one of confidence gained and then
squandered let's start with Terror which
was a cryptocurrency launched in 2018 by
a Brash South Korean entrepreneur named
dokwan people had faith in Terror in
part because Quan exuded confidence
hearing is on Twitch responding to a
question about the volatility of
companies in his space I wonder how many
of these companies you think are
entering the space just because it's hot
and there's a lot of funding versus the
ones that will still be here you know
like two to five years later 95 were
gonna die yeah 95 are going to die okay
but uh yeah there's also entertainment
in watching companies that too I mean
that's pretty cocky but I guess he is
kind of right there can be entertainment
in watching a company die incidentally I
believe that's the new slogan for Max
hey do you like HBO but want to add to
the property brothers and also don't
like HBO Max there's entertainment in
watching a company die
Quan's company made something called a
stable coin the idea of which is that
unlike something like Bitcoin it would
always be worth a stable amount so one
unit of Terror or UST would always equal
one US dollar and the way they
guaranteed this was truly absurd because
rather than simply collecting a dollar
for every unit of Terror that it issued
which would make sense it instead tied
its value to a different coin Luna which
it had also made up and said that it
would turn Luna into Terra and Terra
into Luna with a special algorithm if
that sounds both complicated and stupid
to you it is here is how the company
explained it and just know you don't
need to understand anything that's
happening here because it doesn't make
sense let's imagine the entire Terra
economy as a pool size of the pool is
determined by the total supply of UST
if more people want UST The Tide Rises
and if less people want UST the Tide
Falls to bring back the water level to
one dollar we can expand the pool by
introducing a new supply of UST
but where does new UST come from
at Terror we've designed a machine that
swaps one dollar worth of lunar to one
UST okay imagine if someone came up to
you when you're at the ATM and said give
me that money and instead I'll give you
blocks one block is always worth one
dollar and the reason I can guarantee
that is I'll sell as many fleesels as it
takes to make that happen also I make
the fleesels you would probably say no
wouldn't you immediately but if they
then said I do it with a special
algorithm suddenly you might think that
they know something that you don't well
that's basically what happened here and
to be fair some people did see the
problem with this in 2018 an analyst
looked at Tara's business model and said
this is crazy this obviously doesn't
work and Quan would shame anyone who
dared question his model after a
financial writer raise questions about
the vulnerabilities of crypto Quan
tweeted I don't debate the poor on
Twitter and for a while his confidence
worked at its height Luna's total value
belonged to more than 40 billion dollars
the Washington Nationals entered the
partnership with them Quan's followers
call themselves lunatics and one of his
backers even got a lunar themed tattoo
and that is a bold move from crypto Moby
there I would say that is the worst
tattoo I've ever seen but I have also
seen this tattoo of R Kelly with the
words I don't see nothing wrong and
that's around five percent worse
but we now know according to the SEC the
algorithm didn't work as they'd claimed
in fact at one point in 2021 Terra
nearly collapsed and while Juan told
people that the crisis had been averted
thanks to his algorithm saying it was
automatically self-healing it turns out
it was only saved by the deliberate
intervention of a third party which was
quietly purchasing large quantities of
Terror to restore its value but last May
a few big trades destabilized the price
of Terror prompting a panic in which
both Terror and lunar holders started
selling on mass and since they weren't
backed by anything but Good Vibes both
coins value were trading at essentially
zero and the opposing it raised tens of
billions of dollars of value as for Quan
he now faces charges in multiple
countries and he actually went on the
run for a bit but before he was caught
managed to find some emotional support
on a crypto podcast here he is mid
thought getting surprised by an
unexpected guest
your
like you haven't slept in a while and
like you feel almost
um
holy it's unboxing scroudy hey
though um I just wanted to let you know
Jail's not that bad it's um
it's not the worst thing you know so
don't don't fret if that I hope it does
happen but if it does happen it's not
that bad
good to know wow I don't think there's
ever been a more cursed Zoom call and
I'm very much including That Celebrity
imagine video
and quick side note if you're wondering
if Jim Cramer ever saw Manish shkreli's
Scandal coming you should know that
shkreli actually got his start at Jim
Cramer's hedge fund so another eight in
the hole for the crime game but it's not
just cryptocurrencies that can be built
on Sand the same can happen with crypto
Banks which are already a bit of a
misnomer because unlike traditional
Banks they are not regulated or indeed
in short but they are firms that will
hold your crypto pay you interest and
lend it out and that brings us to our
second company Celsius one of the
biggest crypto Banks founded by this guy
Alex machinski now his so Wholesales
pitch as you can see from his cool
t-shirt was banks are not your friends
which is clearly true but he really
doubled down on that message in ads like
this banks are not your friends we all
know that and we decided to create a
replacement for the banking system right
something that acts in your best
interest a place where you can actually
have your money work for you not just
you work for your money and basically
three years since we launched the
product we've paid a billion dollars
back to the community
now despite the fact that he sounds
exactly like Tommy wizzo in the room
machinski built one of the biggest
crypto lenders with more than 12 billion
dollars in deposits and one of the ways
that he did this was
awesomeness would get up to 18 interest
rates on their deposits that first is
the average of 0.06 then being offered
by traditional Banks and he'd like to
say that Banks could actually pay those
sorts of rates if they wanted to adding
somebody is lying either the bank is
lying or Celsius is lying and hey porque
no Los Dos two things can be true like
how Frankie Mooney's could be both 37
years old and 12 at the same time or how
the rock can be one of the highest paid
actors in Hollywood despite never
actually acting
went out of his way to build trust among
customers holding weekly live stream
amas sometimes featuring dumb stunts
like when he started one wearing a
Mandalorian mask and on these calls he
would brag about all the great things
that his company was doing for people
while occasionally engaging in the
single worst attempt at a dab I have
ever seen the beauty of what Celsius
managed to do is that we deliver a yield
we pay it to the people who would never
be able to do it themselves we take it
from the rich and we beat the index okay
that's like going through the Olympics
and getting 15 medals in in 15 different
fields okay
what the was that a heads up dab
and to be honest why a dab at all it's
not 2015 and you're not a guest on Ellen
also you're 57 years old that
demonstrates a lack of judgment frankly
terrifying in someone supposedly running
a financial institution and yet
machinski insisted we are probably one
of the least risky businesses that
Regulators worldwide have ever seen
which was just flagrantly untrue a
counter-pointed examiner later found
that he was making incredibly risky
loans and was also using customers money
to pay the high yields that he'd
promised which sure sounds like the
textbook definition of a Ponzi scheme
eventually Celsius started minting its
own coin to inflate its balance sheet a
coin that his own employees said was
worthless and that its price should be
zero what even said that the whole thing
was very Ponzi like and at one point the
company's former Finance Chief said we
are doing something possibly illegal and
definitely not compliant
and what an office that must have been
to work in find yourself wandering over
to Cheryl's desk like hey girl great top
uh quick question are we like doing
great
because I'm getting like major crime
Vibes in here
also have you seen our boss dab
and when Celsius inevitably collapsed
people got hurt especially because in
the fine print the company's terms of
you stated that customers transferred
all rights of ownership in their crypto
assets by depositing them in a salesy's
account meaning that when people try to
withdraw their money they found out it
legally wasn't theirs anymore and while
Celsius machinski have not been
criminally charged tens of thousands of
customers still have digital assets
trapped on the platform and Celsius has
reported that it owes them 4.7 billion
dollars all of which is enough to make
you think that while banks are not your
friends this guy may actually be your
enemy so so we've got money and
a bank which brings us back to
Sam bankman freed and FTX it was
basically a whole trading
platform the pitch was that FTX was an
exchange where you could buy and sell
cryptocurrencies just like stocks and
its ease was emphasized in ads like this
one with Steph Curry the play in
hindsight like a bit of a red flag
this is Steph Curry the world's leading
expert on cryptocurrency I'm not okay
quit messing around man give me some
tips on crypto no but you are an expert
right no I'm not an expert and I don't
need to be with FTX I have everything I
need to buy sell and trade crypto safely
we all have towards semicolons you never
a hundred percent using one of those are
you it's a real go with God punctuation
although we'll say it kind of makes
sense that they get Steph Curry for that
ad considering that he's already a
spokesperson for Subway a restaurant
whose slogan is officially eat fresh but
spiritually trust us it's tuna and
for a while that pitch worked pretty
well fgx held a conference in the
Bahamas less than a year ago that
included a panel with Tony Blair and
Bill Clinton and appearances by Orlando
Bloom and Katy Perry Tom Brady was even
there in person too making videos like
this
what's up guys I'm here with my boy Sam
from FTX we're at crypto Bahamas
conference we're going to start the day
we're gonna do some tick tocks for you
guys and uh it's gonna be amazing day
we'll get started we'll do a uh get
ready with me
Sam where you going bro no Sam Sam from
one Ohio six to another
never stand that close to Tom Brady it's
doing you no favors there is a reason
that I've never been photographed with
Chris Hemsworth no matter how much he
begs for it now the joke there was that
Sam was a shy self-effacing genius and
that's the general vibe that he went for
it's why he dressed like every day was
laundry day and combed his hair with a
balloon
obviously we now know that things Came
Crashing Down But even after they did
SBF was still defensive about what he'd
built a lot of people look at you and
see Bernie Madoff yeah
I mean I don't think that's who I am at
all but I understand why they're saying
that people lost money when you look at
the classic Bernie Madoff story there
was no real business
there the whole thing as I understand it
I think was was just one one big Ponzi
scheme right fgx that was a real
business yeah but was it though because
I understand that no one wants to admit
that their business was a scam it's the
same reason no parent wants to admit
that their child sucks saying it out
loud makes it real doesn't it but the
truth is some kids do some kids are just
to put it nicely not a fun hang
you still love them of course but do you
like them
exactly but but it is worth
understanding just what sbf's real
business consisted of because it turns
out that in addition to FTX he had a
hedge fund called Alameda and he also
produced his own coin because of course
he did called ftt and very basically
according to authorities what he did was
filled up his hedge funds books with the
coin that he produced using his exchange
to inflate that coin's price and once
his hedge fund had a giant stash of his
own coin it used as collateral to take
out several loans essentially the feds
say that he created fake money inflated
its price and then borrowed real money
against that but wait I'm not done
because he was also taking money from
actual FDX customers the ones remember
who were putting money into FTX because
Steph Curry told them it was safe and
then loaning it back to his hedge fund
the whole thing was honestly pretty
blatant after everything collapsed a new
CEO came in to handle the bankruptcy is
he told Congress he was shocked at just
how sloppy and poorly run everything was
this is really old-fashioned an
embezzlement this is just taking money
from customers
and using it for your own purpose not
sophisticated at all literally you know
there's no record keeping whatsoever
they use QuickBooks multi-billion dollar
company using QuickBooks QuickBooks
QuickBooks it's true they used
QuickBooks and look I'm no accountant I
mean I should be I look like my most
formative childhood memories were in an
H R Block I look like I fell into a vat
of radioactive itemized receipts I don't
like what it What appears if you say
Microsoft Excel into the mirror three
times but I'm actually not accountant
and yet even
as for a company of that size is absurd
that man also revealed that FTX let
thousands of uncashed deposit checks sit
around like junk mail and approved
millions of dollars of expense reports
via emoji on slack and I'm dying to know
which Emoji they used because we all
know emojis on slack have very specific
meanings for instance thumbs up means
I'm done with this conversation this
means I'm too lazy to type thank you
this means I'm dying inside don't talk
to me this means feeling cheeky let's go
and this one means look at me I'm a
Italian but but I've yet to discover
which emoji means go ahead spend
millions of dollars of company funds but
if I had to guess I'd say it's probably
money bath but it is it is no wonder
that that new CEO has said never in my
career have I seen such a complete
failure of corporate controls and such a
complete absence of trustworthy
financial information has occurred here
which is really saying something given
his career includes overseeing the
bankruptcy of Enron and if you don't
remember how bad Enron was us Google it
I can't do everything for you suffice to
say it's very bad
the through line in all three companies
I've talked about tonight is them
confidently presenting a veneer of
expertise even as beneath the surface
they were a complete show and it
kind of says something that even as they
imploded all three of the men behind
them were still trying to Bluster their
way out of it that interview where SBF
insisted his company was a real business
came after it had declared chapter 11 as
for dokwan he spent time pushing a new
Terror 2.0 coin and was finally arrested
last month after a lengthy Pursuit
including at one point him tweeting that
he wasn't on the run from South Korean
authorities to which they responded that
he was obviously on the Run
and as for mashinski here is audio of
him trying to Buck up his team at an all
hands meeting even as his company was
crumbling around him
well perhaps he filed for bankruptcy
twice
right
does it make the Pepsi taste less good
right Delta file for bankruptcy right do
you not fly Delta because they filed for
bankruptcy
oh it's not the same thing isn't it
crashed four billion planes and drinking
Pepsi gave everyone Infinity diarrhea
then yeah people might lose trust in
them and for pretty good reason
and the thing is there are still
companies out there making all the same
claims that you've seen tonight and I'm
not saying that they are all scams maybe
these three are the exceptions although
they would be joining all the other
exceptions that we haven't had time to
talk about tonight from bitconnect to
quadriga to so so many more but the
truth is in a financial system where the
only real currency is confidence
scammers are going to thrive and I know
that we usually like to point to a
solution at the end of our stories and
that often means calling for more
regulation but I'm not sure that's a
good idea here the danger is regulation
might give this sector more legitimacy
assessment looks safe when it is clearly
not and that in turn might entice Banks
to start getting more involved in crypto
giving the sector even more legitimacy
and also exposing all of us to its
volatility it really says a lot that one
of the leading advocates for the
government to strongly regulate crypto
was Sam bankman freed and look I'm
absolutely not saying that we should get
rid of crypto entirely it could
eventually be useful maybe the third
time that we talk about it we'll all be
using a digital coin to buy everything I
doubt it but I can't predict the future
after all I'm no Jim Cramer
but but we should recognize that right
now the main thing you can really do
with crypto is gamble with more crypto
this is all still a casino so if you do
want to invest do your own due diligence
never put in more than you can afford to
lose and if you ever see someone doing
this run